the immigration debate played a key role
in the midterms exit polls show it was
the second most important issue among
voters from both parties after health
care for 75% of Republican voters it was
the most important concern President
Trump made immigration his central theme
in the final weeks of the campaign
remember his speeches and he also spent
thousands thousands of troops to the
border ahead of the arrival of a caravan
of Central American migrants Matea via
al is in Donna Texas on the us-mexico
border
Maria good morning well good morning
guys you know the midterm elections
might be over but this military base it
is just getting started we have seen
more military vehicles show up more
equipment more troops and take a look
just over my shoulder you can actually
see in the last 24 hours these giant
tents showed up the framework is here
and several generators have been brought
in now we watch more than 300 troops
pour into the small border town of Dona
Texas for now they're putting up barbed
wire to fill the gaps along the border
where there is no wall and they are
setting up their home base the rare use
of active-duty military has led to
criticism that this was a political move
ahead of the midterms it's now clear the
issue made an impact on voters exit
polls show Americans are split nearly
half say Trump's immigration policies
are too tough but nearly the same amount
filled the policies are either not tough
enough or about right now just last week
the president said he would use
executive power to acquire migrants
seeking asylum in the United States to
apply only at legal ports of entry but
he will face some new obstacles passing
any sweeping immigration legislation
with a house that is now controlled by
the Democrats now an interest in fact
this location right here back in 2016
was used as a temporary processing
facility when we saw that influx of
unaccompanied minors as of right now
that central migrant caravan that was
coming up through Mexico we know that
it's shrunk down from about 7,000 people
to about 4,000 people from where I'm
standing right at this minute they are
about 600 miles away and that translates
to about three to four weeks
bianna yeah and the president said he's
gonna be sending thousands of troops
there as well Miriah thank you